yeah i look at these things i looked at
them 10 years ago and i have this curse
i can see where things are going and
i think oh this is going in this
colossally stupid direction and it's it
can't be the case that it's really going
to get to that point is it and then it
just happens over and over and over and
over
and this bill is the most
this makes bill c-16 look like child's
play exactly
[Music]
hello everyone i've brought three people
together with me today
to discuss
bill c-67
uh ontario bill
that
is entitled racial equity
in the education system
barbara k is a columnist for the
canadian newspaper national post she
also writes for the epoch times and
western standard online
david haskell
is at wilford laurier operating
primarily within the field of sociology
of religion but makes occasional forays
into communication studies
his teaching and research focuses on
religion in canada media in canada
bruce pardee is executive director of
rights probe and professor of law at
queen's university he spearheaded
resistance to and ultimate repeal
of the law society of ontario's
statement of principles policy that
required ontario lawyers to attest to
their ideological purity to maintain
their license to practice
and so i brought these people together
today invited these people to come
together today to discuss this bill
which the conservatives in ottawa to
their great discredit
are
supporting
uh and so
barbara maybe we'll start with you you
wrote an article
a little while ago a couple of days ago
in the epoch times trying to alert
ontarians and canadians particularly
let's say
in the center and on the right
to the degree that those exist in canada
to
the purported to what you see as the
dangers of this bill so why is a bill
that's hypothetically aimed at something
as awful as racism let's say
what concerns do you have about it and
why
well this bill 67 which is heading is
soon heading well is heading for third
reading before a final vote uh and it's
it is billed as an anti-racism bill it's
going to give anti-racist instruction to
children in the educational system
but the bill is in fact um pretty well a
clone of the programs in the united
states that are being resisted all over
the place
because it depends entirely on critical
race theory for the ideas that are in
the uh program and uh for the the uh the
rules that are going to govern it uh and
it is basically uh
it calls itself anti-racism but in fact
uh it it is a a very racist program
because uh it deals in a group identity
group uh
um
framing all questions of of
victimhood in terms of identity groups
it
says that it's going to oppose
anti-indigenous racism anti-black racism
and anti-asian racism plus anti-semitism
and islamophobia but in fact they do not
include anti-caucasian
racism because that is going to be the
one race racism that is not only going
to be allowed but
encouraged according to critical race
theory which i know jordan you've spoken
about many times
the basic
hypothesis that we're pursuing in this
discussion is that
under the ages of something as ethically
admirable let's say
as the absence of racism or even
promoting the absence of racism what
this bill actually does is
bring in a whole set of ideas that have
virtually nothing to do with racism per
se under the guise of a moral endeavor
and make it
both likely and necessary that people
abide by this particular propagandistic
ethic in order to be teachers in ontario
schools and certainly to be promoted and
so i'll just detail some of the details
of the bill so that people are aware of
this so for example
performance appraisals shall include
competencies related to a teacher's
anti-racism awareness whatever that is
and efforts to promote racial equity
news subsection
301 7.11 requires the minister to
establish policies and guidelines with
respect to promoting racial equity in
schools and boards must establish and
implement racial equity plans the
the higher education quality council of
ontario
will have to have a member who will be
an expert in racial equity in the
post-education center and that all
members must have a proven commitment to
racial equity or take anti-racism
training
um and there's a variety
of additional details that are relevant
and
what we're what we're discussing today
is the fact that
all of this
means that the education system in the
narrow and the broad sense will be
oriented towards a set of policies that
are radically left in their orientation
by necessity
and that
there will be punishments put in place
for failure to adopt that ideological
standpoint
so
and and this
and this is a supposedly conservative
government who's bringing this in
uh the problem with the bill i think is
that uh the word equity is used
54 times in this bill
but you don't ever see the word equality
and the problem
even amongst politicians who are
supposed to understand the philosophy
guiding their own party
uh is that the
they seem to glaze over with the word
equity because it sounds a lot like
equality and it sounds like a good thing
um and uh
equity is predicated on the idea that if
there are any differences in outcome
between any groups imaginable so those
could be groups defined by gender they
could be groups defined by race they
could be groups defined by sex if there
any differences outcome of any sort that
that's not only indication of a profound
and systemic bias characterizing
whatever domain
is being questioned but that it's
incumbent upon all the members of that
domain
to
regard themselves as prejudiced and
biased and to view the
non-equal outcomes as evidence of
systemic bias that's the tie-in critical
race theory let's say
so what's wrong with the proposition
that's precisely what the problem is
with it and
i'm very happy uh for bruce to to uh
amplify on it uh because he understands
it much better than
any than i do well that's not that's
that's obviously not true but let me
just contrast two different ideas
[Music]
anti-racism which this bill promotes and
insists upon and non-races
those two things sound equivalent but
they're opposites actually
non-racism is the attitude that your
race doesn't really matter and that you
should be treated as a human being
and that the same rules and standards
should apply to everybody
notwithstanding the group that you
belong to
anti-racism is the opposite
anti-racism insists
that your race is fundamentally
important
and that being white
means that you are both privileged
and probably racist
and that is an ideology and that
this bill intends to make that ideology
compulsory
inside the school systems and inside the
universities
yeah so so let's let's add some more
details that are useful here so
any
a person
who is going to be a teacher now has to
successfully complete any prescribed
examinations and training in anti-racism
in order to be issued a certificate of
qualification and registration so that
means you have to abide by this
political ideology
which is even regarded by moderate
leftists in the united states and
certainly by centrists as radically left
in its fundamental orientation
it also means that uh colleges that
provide such training must be undertaken
by
all the institutions that are going to
train teachers so it is an attempt to
capture
the entire education system
and subserve it to the purposes of a
given ideology and what ideology in one
fell swoop and that ideology involves
claims like
the the idea that
all of the institutions that
characterize the west certainly
countries like canada are fundamentally
racist and oppressive in their
orientation and their aim and that any
attempts to
uh constitute an argument that might
dispute that are in and of themselves
indications of exactly that racism
um and and well that's not as far as it
goes so
and it's interesting to to to note
how um
disparaging this approach is to
everybody on the one hand it allows and
promotes
racism
against white people but at the same
time it disparages insults patronizes
people who are not white as though they
are not really capable human beings on
their own and must be counted according
to their group and compensated for
whatever wrong or victimhood that they
have been uh subjected to so it is it's
bad all around it is
it is disrespectful of everybody
and essentially it makes not being an
activist
uh a a matter of professional misconduct
yeah i was just going to say what we
might want to look at is we're talking
that teachers are going to have to
receive trainings so let's just look at
that for a moment and say well what kind
of books are they going to read in order
to become anti-racist so right now the
most
popular the most
well selling or best-selling
books are white fragility by uh deangelo
and
i can't remember her first name and then
there's
robin d'angelo and then there's uh
ibrahim kindy who who actually has a
book called how to be anti-racist
now what people will find interesting is
we keep saying that anti-racism
is in fact racism and i want to give a
quote from kendy's book now this book is
how to be anti-racist
and he says this the only remedy to
racist discrimination is anti-racist
discrimination
the only remedy to past discrimination
is present discrimination
what the these ideas
are saying
is
discrimination
is a good thing if it's applied to the
group that is the oppressor and in this
case it's going to be white kids at our
public schools right now it's all
predicated that's all predicated on
acceptance of the idea and this people
have to understand this that the
fundamentally appropriate
level of conceptualization of all human
beings is their group identity not their
individual nature and so it's okay to
punish one group for its past crimes
because the group is the proper level of
analysis
and that's an absolutely anti-western
idea it's the most profound perhaps of
anti-conservative ideas that's for sure
but it's also a profoundly anti-liberal
idea in the classical sense no group
guilt here there's no presumption of
innocence right if you're the member of
an oppressive group then you're guilty
and if you're the member of an oppressed
group then you're a victim
that's right right and that's what's
that's what will be taught in our
classrooms right and and so let's go
ahead barbara
well i was just going to say that
although these ideas are borrowed from
american uh american writers and
influencers uh i have the idea uh
doesn't say so in the in in the bill but
i'm i'm morally certain that uh
the a lot of the intense discussion and
a lot of the blame blame laying
is going to focus more on indigenous
matters uh because that
the the indigenous
settler history is the not the
equivalent in fact but it is the
equivalent in terms of the moral
narrative uh in canada as slavery was in
the united states the moral the original
sin of americans is slavery and
canadians original sin is
colonialism
so i have the idea that that uh it's
going to be not just white but settler
privilege that's going to be emphasized
and one of the things that always
bothered me about that was that in the
united states slavery was in fact uh a
practice that was something that all
americans i mean not all americans but
the americans who had slaves they were
american citizens they were
they were people involved in a practice
that we now
consider odious
but in in canada uh we were
the the whole the whole residential
school system or the way that indians or
indigenous people were treated in
general was always a function of the
government or the institutional um
people in charge of the residential
schools the churches or whatever no no
canadian citizens were ever involved in
abusing uh indigenous peoples or in
setting policy uh for that matter so uh
for that to be made an equivalent kind
of sin uh that you're you're a settler
uh you're a settler stock because you're
white this is something that that has
kind of taken on uh you know this idea
that that that that uh the residential
schools were a genocide and that all of
indigenous history uh in canada and it's
an ongoing genocide
from the point of view of our prime
minister
this is a narrative that i think if
you're going to push back against that
in these classrooms that too will be
considered
racism and that that actually i find a
very disturbing kind of concept
david bruce any comments
so it might be
worthwhile just to just to note
how extreme
this is in terms of its dictation
of both
attitude thought and and speech inside
schools inside universities and once you
understand what it is you might think
well but how you know how can this be
it's completely contrary to the whole
idea
of having schools and universities that
engage in thinking and challenge and
debate and one of the reasons why it's
so extreme is that it comes to us from
critical theory now jordan you mentioned
critical race theory and that's
absolutely what it is it's critical it's
mandatory critical race theory in the
schools and universities but critical
race theory itself of course is a sort
of an independent branch of critical
theory and that's a larger idea
essentially an
anti-western ideology which
which regards all the features and
values of the enlightenment as
inherently evil if you like and to be
rejected and
and even very basic ideas like
uh evidence and consistency and and
debate and pluralism all those things
are essentially out
and you can see those
that that rejection in the bill the bill
basically says that if you wish to
debate
the validity
of anti-racism
then you are on thin ice there's even a
an offense
included in the bill which says that if
you disrupt or attempt to disrupt the
proceedings of a school or a class
through the use of racist language
then you are guilty of an offense and
the problem is that what they mean or
going to mean by racist language
is language that denies the validity of
the ideology that they're promoting so
for example and who knows exactly but
here's a possibility
if you insist upon debating the validity
of anti-racism in a classroom by saying
no i believe all lives matter and i
believe all people are equal equal
regardless of their race or color
then you might very well be in violation
of of this provision
so we should delve into that a little
bit more too so
the the fundamental
claim of the critical theorist types is
that
we use a particular kind of instrumental
narratives to structure our perceptions
and actions
and that that instrumental narrative is
essentially predicated upon the use of
power
and so that would be the arbitrary
uh
the arbitrary use of compulsion
to demand the compliance of other people
particularly in relationship to their
group so that what western culture is in
its essence and and the attitudes and
actions of everyone who composes that
culture is nothing but the attempt to
utilize arbitrary power to extract
excess resources from other people
through compulsion
to hoard it for
the purposes of that group let's say and
that all claims about
equality of opportunity or sovereignty
of the individual or even existence of
the individual for that matter or
individual responsibility all of that
where the conservatives operate that's
nothing but justification for the
arbitrary use of power and compulsion
and so even to make those arguments so
this is one of the things that's so
pernicious about the free speech debate
the critical theorists don't engage in
debate about who should have free speech
and should and who shouldn't
their claim is that the whole idea of
free speech is nothing but the attempt
to add a moralizing layer to the
will to power that exploits
and all of this language that we see in
this bill is derived from that
theoretical background
yes
now i i you know i'm i'm putting myself
in the place of
the audience who's listening to us speak
and all of us have been steeped in
critical race theory for years we've
been looking at it and saying what a
terrible thing it is and i'm trying to
picture
how people could get a hold of this and
maybe maybe the example is what we
entered in on so here we have this bill
that really will
promote division in our school system
and the conservative uh the progressive
conservatives of ontario who are
ostensibly supposed to be conservative
all voted in favor of this bill and even
um there's another party we have now the
ontario party uh rick nichols is the
sitting mp they have a specific
policy platform against this kind of
stuff and even he voted in favor so
what's going on there
what's going on there is that
the the wording the wording is is just
beguiling for everyone we just can't it
for us to try and explain is so
difficult because
the left has really commandeered the
definition of words when someone sees
anti-racism they think of course i want
to be anti-racist so perhaps let's give
the benefit of the doubt
maybe the conservatives were just fooled
i know that this fella rick nichols on
the ontario party was fooled he had no
idea that this bill actually will
promote racism in our schools
you know david since you mentioned the
ontario party's platform
uh i actually think that their uh their
policy with regard to
teaching
what they have to say
speak in our audience i think might be
interested to know what would be the
opposite what would be what would be a
curriculum that taught
that racism was bad and all these things
were bad but that had a curriculum that
was fair to every student and they
actually spell it out and what they say
is uh their platform uh in their
platform they would make it illegal for
any teacher school administrator or any
school board official to teach
disseminate or promote materials to
students that ex
explicitly or implicitly state
one
that males and females do not exist as
separate biological realities because of
course gender is included subsumed under
the racist umbrella
uh
will not be allowed to state
that any individual by virtue of his
race or sex is inherently privileged
racist sexist or oppressive whether
consciously or subconsciously
that will not be allowed to state that
an individual should be discriminated
against or receive adverse treatment
because of the individual's race or sex
and you can't say that an individual by
virtue of race or sex bears
responsibility for actions committed in
the past by other members of the same
race or sex
and finally that uh any particular
canadian province or canada itself is
fundamentally or irredeemably racist or
sexist these are all the things you
won't be allowed to say and that i think
is if you asked
most canadians do you think that sounds
fair they would say yes that that's
exactly we might want to point out that
the entire
educational system that's associated
with classical western values is
the
most
successful manifestation
of the most fundamentally
non-racist ethos ever developed and that
ethos insisted that each individual
regardless of their group membership
was of intrinsic worth and characterized
by natural rights and that it was to
their advantage and to the advantage of
all others that no arbitrary barriers be
put forward against them
as they manifested their attempts to
take their place in the world in a
manner that was
reciprocally beneficial to everyone
around them and there isn't an ethos
that's more fundamentally non-racist
than that one and it's time for
conservatives and liberals alike to
start to stop being apologetic about
that
agreed agreed yeah can we just add just
to dive back into critical theory for a
moment jordan picking up what you were
saying earlier
so i believe it was james lindsay who is
an american uh critic of social justice
and critical theory he i think he was
the one who coined the term the the iron
law of woke projection you were talking
earlier about
critical theory
characterizing western society is
essentially based upon a power
relationship and nothing else
abuse of power relationships in which
everything that happens really is a a
search for power underneath the surface
so what is happening here is that
the the the woke the critical theorists
the critical race theorists are actually
turning western society into exactly
that
and this bill is an example
of the simple application of power to
insist upon an ideology and to
essentially cast out or cancel or
or accuse a professional misconduct
those people who will not go along with
the story that that's that's a pure
power play
and there's really nothing nothing else
in it it
rejects the idea that there might be
another point of view it rejects the
idea of pluralism it rejects the idea of
debate
and
it's it this is called neo-marxism for a
reason and the reason is that marx was
the one who came on board and said look
western society is a power struggle but
he he emphasized the economic struggle
between the upper and lower classes and
the critical theorists ditched that
particular struggle in favor of the
struggle over identity politics in
between different but they use exactly
the same language and the same
conceptualization and i want to i want
to reiterate a couple of things add
another detail so first of all here's
another detail from the bill
the ministry of training colleges and
universities act is amended to add a new
section
which sets out anti-racism and racial
equity requirements
that apply to every college of applied
arts and technology and every university
that receives ongoing operating funds
from the government for the purposes of
secondary education so
in that one section alone which is only
a small fragment of this bill we now
have a demand from the most radical of
the radical leftists uh possessed by
critical theory and also critical race
theory that every single educational
institution in ontario at the highest
level that receives ongoing function
will now be
mandated to accept that ideology
now i just can't i just can't forgive
the conservatives for not noticing this
this is appalling like if there's if
they're that blind we're in real trouble
because
you shouldn't be that blind by this
point in time if you haven't gotten on
to the fact that equity doesn't mean
equality of opportunity which is what
everyone wants it to mean then you have
been asleep
at the switch for like 10 years well
things are falling apart around you yeah
at least so
at least yes at least at least 10 years
yeah and and to see
written by an ndp member right this bill
didn't that clue them in yeah let's talk
about her for a bit
that should have been an alarm bell
right there the the drafter of this bill
uh had been the head of equity at
laurier university and had drafted the
sexual violence policy uh under which
lindsay shepherd who many people will
remember in 2017
for having shown her students a graduate
student for having shown her students a
balanced discussion in which
you featured jordan uh on gender
pronouns and shown that uh segment of of
that panel discussion to her class was
was invited in to be interrogated um in
in a session
with several members of the
administration and staff faculty
but
they told her that she was transphobic
because she had uh she had breached the
sexual violence policy which this
individual who wrote this
uh
horrible bill uh you know that and as
you as you say that conservatives could
let this pass is really terrible one of
the terrible things about
racism as it as they understand it is
that the offense of of having said or
done something racist
is judged
not by your intention but by the person
who is claims to be offended uh so much
for the presumption of innocence
exactly
just so we know what's at stake here
right the new the new ethic is it
doesn't matter what you intend all that
matters is the impact on the person
claiming victim status they don't even
have to demonstrate that in any
important way that they were in fact
victimized by the claim or demonstrate
any and let's let's just delve into that
for a minute because one of the things
that's in this bill that's so cute
is also the establishment of the
necessity of putting in
boards of inquisition to work to which
students can apply if they ever feel
that they have been offended in any
manner by anything that anyone says now
let's make two things clear there you
people do say offensive things and i do
believe that there's such thing as hate
speech because speech can be pretty
vicious that's not the point here the
point is is that
there are now there will be boards of
inquisition set up at all educational
institutes in ontario if this bill
passes that anyone with a grudge can
weaponize against anyone they want and
if you don't think that will happen
you're a fool because it happens all the
time and it's happening more and more at
the college level board for for
physicians and psychologists and at the
law society and
so and this is going to make the
establishment of those inquisitorial
bureaucracies which are basically
extrajudicial uh
structures right operating outside the
normal judicial system without the
presumption of innocence it's going to
make the establishment of those
mandatory and so again i can't believe
that conservatives could be so ungodly
blind it's it's it's it's
and categorically
surreal
one one of the and again i'm just trying
to bring this back to the common person
and say
how do how does this work and and maybe
a way to understand it is
when you think the word is going by its
traditional definition or what you think
it should mean it simply doesn't
so when we see equity
all of us think well equality we think
that we want to see people
have equal opportunity but it doesn't
mean that but related to anti-racism
anti-racism means
yes you should discriminate against one
group
in this way it's whites but not only
that as bruce has already suggested it's
very racist toward people of color
because it suggests that you have to rig
the game in order for them to succeed
and that in and of itself is the height
of racism but also denies it it dies
them the i've been thinking about this
in regards to so there are claims from
the critical theorist types for example
just so everyone knows that the concepts
of merit and excellence are in
themselves
racist in the same way that the concept
of free speech or individual sovereignty
is racist and so i think well of all the
demoralizing things that you could
possibly tell
people who are on the
let's say on the margins of society the
most demoralizing thing you could
possibly tell them is that
excellence the idea of excellence or the
idea of merit is nothing but a plot
conjured up by your oppressors to
subvert you and that therefore if you
strive in a meritorious way towards
excellence that you're doing nothing but
identifying with the oppressor
and you think think about the black
music scene in the united states i
always think about that because
the black culture in the united states
has been so
absolutely brilliant in its musical
innovation and it's changed the entire
culture of the united states and the
entire culture of the world and to tell
to for me to think about someone like
billie holiday
or
louis armstrong as something other than
a
manifestation of individual merit in the
purest sense in the purest and most
redeeming sense is to me utterly it's
appalling and shaming and then to deny
that this that same
movement towards excellence in a given
domain to individuals on the margin is
the worst thing you can do for them
being put forth under the guise of
compassion and benevolence it's
sickening i agree and conservatives
should be ashamed of themselves for
being so goddamn dumb i completely agree
very infantilizing it's very
infantilizing to speak of of of people
from other backgrounds or other races uh
as as without moral agency or without
the ability to to compete on their own
terms against uh the people of other
races i i i agree with you jordan and i
go ahead bruce well i was going to say
that
it's also ironic tragedy because
the the things that the ideas
that would protect and promote people
who are not privileged
are things like merit i mean the idea of
having standardized tests for entry into
universities for example
is the thing that gives people who are
not wealthy not privileged not connected
that the the opportunity to prove what
it is that they can do
the irony here is that everything is
upside down in order to understand this
you just have to take your assumption
and flip it upside down about what
racism means about what privilege means
essentially
this is a program
that protects the privilege of all those
people who are yelling about privilege
if you take away the merit idea then you
pull the rug out from underneath all
those non-privileged people to be able
to show that they are deserving of
getting a spot getting a job getting a
you know having well adrian wooldridge
wrote a whole book on on the idea of
merit in the west and so
he he showed historically which i think
is extremely interesting that
the alternative to merit
per se as a
let's say as an index of of selective
value
it has been dynasty and nepotism
so dynasty means that your found your
your hereditary family connections
dominate
uh
what what are are the most important
determinant of how you progress up the
ladder or whether you maintain your
position or it's or it's it's callous
and crass favoritism now you know the
utopians might say well we could scrap
merit and we wouldn't revert to nepotism
or dynasty but we certainly would
instantly because that's what happened
throughout history and so we already
have also we already have
we already have we already we've already
reverted to that i think we've all
once merit on the way out you've got to
have some other way for picking people
and those the ways that are left are
nepotism and favoritism and there's got
to be some criteria for what that is but
it's got nothing to do with the
individual it's got everything to do
with who who your people are
and i mean look at the impact of this
already um we we have asian students who
are applying to the elite schools like
harvard who now can't get in
not because their sats weren't through
the roof
but because
for the means of diversity they're now
excluded
yes we should also point out that in
these in these hypothetically white
supremacist societies that many
people who aren't so easily
what would you say categorized as white
seem to be doing just fine so
indian immigrants for example do
extremely well in the united states and
east asian immigrants do extremely well
in fact both of those groups of people
although i hate to speak in the language
of groups do better economically than
the native born caucasians who are
hypothetically the epicenter of racial
privilege and that's a big
what
stick in the throat of the critical
theorist types and they
they can't adjust their theories to
account for that go ahead barbara one of
the one of the things you're not allowed
to say is that these groups one of the
reasons that they do get ahead is
because they usually have strong uh
family support uh and and a strong uh
work uh values of work work ethic and um
uh yeah well they promote
conscientiousness and so it's very based
yeah exactly from attraction
but you see that you're not allowed to
say that because if you if you talk
about strong families and you talk about
how important fathers are for example
uh that is considered racist
because um
that's like suggesting
well it's both misogynistic and racist
because it's like suggesting that single
mothers can't do
exactly the same work in bringing up uh
productive and and and strong you know
confident children as as
a united family um
a two-parent family and it's also uh
because it's a sore point when you talk
about race is is it also needs it also
means that you validate the oppressive
institution of patreon nuclear marriage
which is obviously nothing but a
manifestation of men's desire and
willingness to dominate women and i mean
nothing but because these theories are
always nothing but
right so let and bruce you talked about
projection
i always think of the critical theorist
types as
manifesting a freudian an unconscious
freudian confession in relationship to
their own motivations is that
people who believe that power is the
fundamental principle that governs
social relations
do they either believe there's some
saintly exception to that or that is
actually what they believe and they
assume everyone else is the same
i've been thinking about this
technically you know and
social relations based on power actually
unstable technically speaking they don't
work in chimps they don't work in rats
they don't work well for psychopaths who
are almost always failures and never
constitute more than three percent of
the population and
it's much
more you're much more likely to
advance in a stable manner if you play
reciprocal games with other people
reciprocal mutually beneficial games
with other people and i think that's the
fundamental principle that animates
western society in its best sense and
then sometimes that's corrupted by power
and and and that's a very different
claim than
its power itself it's the fundamental
ethic right right well it just reminds
me of that of that of that very well
known saying you know power corrupts and
absolute power corrupts absolutely so if
all you've got left is power
then you have a corrupted society and
that's where also think about what that
does let's say okay you accept the
doctrine this is and i want to remind
the listeners this doctrine we're
discussing is the doctrine that is now
being mandated for acceptance across all
ontario institutions of education right
okay so the doctrine is nothing governs
the social relations between people at
every level except the will to power and
that's arbitrary use of arbitrary
compulsion so bruce that means you and i
if our interests differ
we can't engage in productive dialogue
about that because there's no such thing
as productive dialogue and what that
means is that if our interests aren't
aligned momentarily i have to treat you
as an enemy
and i have to assume that all you're
using is your will to power and i have
no other option
but to respond in kind and i cannot
think of a more corrosive cynical and
better way of looking at human beings
than that
can you imagine
the psychological impact on students
if this is what they are getting um a
daily dose of so imagine that like i
imagine you are see it
well you are you are you are a student
you're a student who comes into the
classroom and you're a student of color
and you come in without this
indoctrination and you think i can be
whatever i want to be that's what you're
thinking
and then slowly over time you're told no
the the game is rigged against you you
can't you can't be what you want to be
and perhaps you begin to believe that
and that you would be able to speak to
this more than i jordan but i have to
imagine that there's some psychological
principles out there related to
whether or not you think you can succeed
and if that doesn't have a
self-fulfilling prophecy to it
well look imagine that you're told as a
young person so a young person a young
black guy for example you're told that
you've been
propagandized into believing
that there is such a thing as
as agency and freedom
by people who are using those concepts
to do nothing but exploit you and so to
the degree that you believe you have
agency
that does nothing but provide evidence
that you're a pawn in their game okay so
that's that's what they
have to contend with that demoralizing
and bitterly distrustful view of the
world and then imagine that you're a
young white guy and the whole notion is
your entire culture and all the
institutions that that could that make
it up including marriage
are nothing but the manifestation of the
patriarchal desire to oppress throughout
history and to the degree that you have
any ambition whatsoever at the
individual level that's not ambition
that's laudable that has nothing to do
with you wanting to act as a moral agent
in the world it's nothing but
that corrupt will to power that's
capable of atrocity and you should
squelch it if you're moral and i see
tens of thousands of people around the
world
people that come to my lectures for
example who've been utterly demoralized
by these propositions
like hurt to the core wounded to the
bone and now we're going to make it
mandatory because we're too stupid to
notice what's right in front of us
there was a study there was a study done
in 2019 in the journal of experimental
psychology that looked specifically at
what happens when you teach people about
anti-racism
especially one of its concepts the idea
of white privilege and what they found
was that it did not
make people more sympathetic to poor uh
people of color black people but what it
did do was make people a lot less
sympathetic to disadvantaged whites so
the only thing that this kind of
teaching does is actually create greater
animosity to the disadvantaged white
person which
to my mind if you know that and we have
studies that show that that in and of
itself should be enough to say we can't
do this to our kids um speaking of
david speaking of not doing this to our
kids you would think
that parents some parents would be very
concerned about what their kids are
learning
concerned enough to mobilize and to to
get to coalesce into into activism
groups uh in the united states uh
there's a lot of headway being made by
parents who are fed up with this kind of
stuff there was a tremendous success in
san francisco recently by parents not
parents but but people in general in san
francisco which is an incredibly
progressive city i think there's
something like six percent of people
vote conservative in san francisco and
yet this school board that uh had three
three people were recalled by a petition
drawn up by the
parents uh because they they couldn't
stand the direction it was going in it
was exactly this direction and they they
lost their their jobs um and it was
considered i think 70 percent of people
uh voted
to get these people off the board sorry
the mechanism i i forget but uh it it
was considered quite a victory for the
anti-crt
movement
and uh in the united states there is a
real movement headed up by this
christopher ruffo jordan i'm sure you
know him you've probably
talked to him or followed some of his
work
he has been doing great work in helping
groups to organize parents to uh and
there's now i don't know i i i began my
talk my my column with
uh the numbers were
um
sorry the numbers were uh
that yes in 37 state 87
curriculum transparency bills have been
filed by legislators legislators in 37
states since the beginning of
2022 and introduced in 20 or more states
so pretty soon you're going to start
seeing and you already do in florida and
other other conservative states you're
going to see
uh pushback against this and they're not
going to be allowed to treat
i've been talking to a lot of
conservative types well and democrats
for that matter too by the way who are
concerned that their party is being
pulled far too far to the left
about
the dangers of critical race theory and
critical theory and diversity
inclusivity and equity etc and there is
a wider um degree of awareness
about such things in the united states
um our conservatives in canada are
falling are far behind the curve
david in order in relationship to your
discussion of studies we did a study
at the business school in
rotterdam
and we used a program that helps people
make a future plan
and so imagine so you have to lay out
what you'd like in your life in seven
different areas seven important sub
areas like intimate relationships and
friendships and career and education etc
and uh we looked at four year previous
performance in the business school and
we looked at the relationship between
race gender race sex and performance so
what we saw with the caucasian women
were doing the best followed i believe
by the non-caucasian women and then
caucasian men and then
non-caucasian men
and they did this program which was an
agency program right so it's predicated
on the idea that you could in some sense
chart your own course and the
consequence was that within the next
year if i remember the study exactly the
non-caucasian men had caught up to and
exceeded the highest performing
caucasian women
and we did the same thing at mohawk
college although mohawk never adopted
the program and curses on them for
failing to do so
90 minute plan that was agency-based
dropped their dropout rate among the
young men
50
in the first
year
and so we've been using that program
online but it's a testament to the
utility of personal agency and we could
say look different people
face different barriers as they progress
through life and some of those are
arbitrary prejudices that's for sure but
that doesn't mean that
failing to insist that
personal agency is still a
a reality a redeeming reality and also
that you really have it at your disposal
if you're willing to use it
our cultures just aren't that corrupt
people with agency can make progress
well on that show that's what the
immigrant literature certainly shows in
the united states
absolutely
when you look at um for example i mean
they're always held up uh in in studies
the nigerian blacks in america and in
canada i mean they outperform the white
population
similarly just last year it was the
first time in the history of the bureau
of statistics in the us that that asian
women now make more on average than
white men in the us
and but when you dig into that and you
look at the culture you you have uh
parents who are saying
you can make it
you can do this this is a country where
there is a level playing field and that
kind of uh self-talk or talk from
parents really makes a difference right
but he said it's that level playing
field though that's being threatened
right because
you will by anti-racism
that's what i mean by anti-racism by by
the idea that you will not in fact be
treated as an individual but treated by
the system
as simply a member of your group i mean
let's go just circle back for a moment
to the word equity
and and and describe it in equality
terms right there's there are two
different competing and opposite ideas
about equality the the the traditional
one the classical liberal idea is simply
that
the same rules and standards should be
applied to everybody without regard to
who you are but without regard to your
identity right so so
this is the equality of treatment under
the law concept the idea that like cases
should be decided to like and we don't
we don't care we don't care what race
you are we don't care what sex you are
it doesn't matter
the same legal rules are going to be
applied and justice should be blind
the competing idea
which is substantive equality or if you
like equity
is the idea that the same rules and
standards should not be applied
to every individual but they should be
changed depending upon the group that
you belong to and once that idea gets
incorporated and by the way it has been
incorporated into canadian law over the
past 40 years
and this this bill will incorporate it
into every classroom from k to 12.
that's that's absolutely true but but my
point is that the ground has been laid
the groundwork's been laid already and
and we're we are in a really bad spot
and this this bill is a terrible
terrible thing and needs to be defeated
but it's it's not a sudden thing it is
it is shocking but not surprising
well so let's go back to the issue of
why the conservatives let's say had the
walled over their eyes i mean
they didn't pay any attention to the
fact that it was someone who regards
herself as a democratic socialist uh to
say the least
penned this bill
like that was an alarm bell especially
given her previous activities and then
there's the all the equity language and
i'd like to talk briefly about the
weaponization of guilt because one of
the ways these ideas are put forward is
by accusing people who oppose them of
the most highness motivations
and say for and that will happen
certainly in the aftermath of this
conversation is that the reason that we
oppose this bill is because we are
essentially
racist and
you know if you're a decent person and a
bunch of people come after you and say
you're a racist dear prejudice
especially if you're conscientious and
conservatives tend to be that you're
going to examine your conscience and
you're going to feel set back on your
heels because you know how often you a
bunch of people come and accuse you of
something that's absolutely not true
and so
as conscientious people fall over
themselves to step backwards because
they're willing to take some
responsibility when accused all it does
is allow the people who are pushing
these ideas forward to do it without any
opposition
and you know i was thinking about this a
lot so say well
we're all the beneficiaries to some
degree of our arbitrary talents and the
advantages we've been given even by
history
the right way to respond to that is by
living a responsible
productive and reciprocal life and
trying to make good use of
you know what you've been granted to
granted by grace that's the proper mode
of atonement not to wallow in guilt and
then let ideologues tromp all over you
which is exactly what's happening right
now
you mentioned
the the conservatives again and
i'm i was thinking about uh back in 2020
when the george floyd was thinking
thing was happening um the tragic death
of george floyd and we had doug ford
come out and say that you know ontario
or
bruce or barbara might remember better i
think it was ontario or maybe it was
canada was systemically racist at first
he said no
but it was at that point that i realized
that something's going on within the
conservative party
where they've they've they're imbibing
at the critical race theory tap
sure yeah well it's i think it's part of
this weaponization of guilt go ahead
bruce no i'm just gonna say listen the
the the ontario progressive conservative
party has have not behaved like like
what they claim to be for a long time i
mean you can identify nearly anything
you can include their their their
draconian covet policies they even
include the way that that
doug ford uh stripped uh truckers of
their licenses without due process you
can identify just about anything
but you could say
go ahead no no go ahead bart
well i was going to say you could say
that about the i mean the federal
conservatives are no better
they voted for the conversion bill which
would allow which would insist that
every child that questions that has any
question at all about their their gender
identity should only be affirmed and and
and you shouldn't
doctors would be criminals right right
and they if they looked into any other
uh you know yeah so and criticism women
i'd like to comment on that for a sec
barb if you don't mind because i've
thought about that in relationship to
therapists because
the
mandated requirements for therapeutic
conversations are even more astringent
therapists neither affirm nor deny
what therapists do is attempt to have
truthful conversations with people about
confusing situations and so if i all of
a sudden as a therapist and mandated
to affirm all the choices of my clients
then i'm no longer a therapist what i am
instead is a cowardly advocate for whim
and and now that's law
yes and the conservatives
they all voted for it
uh you could i am sure i am sure that
under bill 67 it will be
considered
they'll call it racist i mean
anti-racist to to deny
that biology is exists on a spectrum
uh if you say
i don't i i don't believe that trans
women are women that will be hate speech
gender wise it'll cover a variety of of
you know or if you say i don't think
that that that male rapists who claim to
be female should be in female prisons in
women's prisons that might be deemed
racist anything that
any of the mantras that that go along
with any of the ideologies that are
presently you know so the the federal
liberals federal conservatives are just
as bad as the provincial ones uh i think
what we're witnessing here is you know
uh
a revolution that's over um
they've won
and and this is mopping up operations
yeah putting these bills in place is
simply you know everybody's lying around
on the battlefield too
too exhausted to put up a fight anymore
so it's like okay uh now you know here
here are the actual
laws
here are the laws that are going to make
sure that we state that that what we
want uh entrenched is going to stay
there forever unless you know and and in
that respect
uh the the u.s has something that we do
not
which is an actual political opposition
you know can it
but
go ahead yeah i'm just saying that that
we are seeing if if we're saying that
the uh the battle's over we still see
the guerrilla fighters oh yeah
right yep and and i mean uh let's get
back to this notion we we do have
some some parties that are trying to
gather support for common sense
and whether it's federally with the the
uh people's party and they're demonized
right the mainstream media hate them so
they're they they don't get any kind of
fair coverage but now at the provincial
level we've got a party like the ontario
party which is putting forth the kind of
ideas that would actually bring unity
and harmony but again they'll be
villainized because the the media
is totally on board with this particular
agenda of critical race theory as well
that's right and
i don't know i'm just going to say that
that the ontario party has zero support
and and the uh ppc people's party uh
couldn't even field they couldn't even
you know get uh maxine bernier into into
office so and
i agree with that and and and a lot of
the pushback in this in the u.s you see
coming from parents themselves like in
virginia for example and the real
question i think in this circumstance
with bill 67 is whether
um a a critical mass of parents once
they find out what this really is as
opposed to what it appears to be
if they would respond by saying you know
no way like heck you're not you're not
educating my children in a system like
that
and
you know that that really remains to be
seen how many
parents in ontario
would would respond in the same way as a
lot of parents have in various places in
the u.s and say this this just won't do
as opposed to
going along with the purveyors canadians
canadians have been
able to
trust in the fundamental integrity of
their social institutions for most of
our 150-year history and so
the default assumption has been
well people generally know what they're
doing if they're leading us and they're
not leading us down the garden path and
the problem with bill like bill c6 bill
67 and getting people to understand it
is that they also have to simultaneously
swallow the fact that our fundamental
institutions educational and political
have become so compromised and so
cooperated by
by derivatives of a narrative so radical
that even most democrats on the left
reject it out hand
well who's going to believe that you
know it's a lot easier to think that
the four of us are you know right-wing
conspiracy theorists and that this is
all nonsense
and in fact it's easier for me to
believe that sometimes than to believe
the alternative but i read this bill and
i know what equity means and i know it's
it's ideological derivatives and the
underlying idea system
so yeah i i've said before that our that
our biggest obstacle is disbelief people
don't believe it people don't believe
that what we're describing could
actually be true it's just so far out of
the zone of what they consider to be
normal life
normal civilized life in this country
that
it's very hard to take in in unless
you've sort of seen it for yourself in
front of your own eyes over and over
again and you're forced to admit that
it's actually happening
so
you know media research is one of the
things i do and um and this isn't my
work but it's a guy named um zach
goldberg he's out of uh
georgia state university anyway zach
looked at what was going on in
mainstream media related to coverage of
race
and
race the word race the word equity the
word anti-racism uh it's gone up by a
thousand
percent
in the last well he's he was marking
from
2013 and 2014
and here's the interesting thing when
you look at other sociological data
during that time racial tensions in
terms of other societal measures were
going down
the united states had a black president
and so it was actually getting better
but if you read the news particularly
the more left-leaning um
so he looked at new york times he looked
at the washington post
it it was saying exactly the opposite
and people were being convinced and in
particular he found mrs goldberg's work
again he found that those people who
were over liberal persuasion were even
more convinced
that that we were going to hell in a
hand basket in terms of racial division
yeah well his work pointed out that as
these
press institutions
got uh started to hire recent graduates
from universities who had been
indoctrinated into this theory they
started using that language in their
articles and that seeped into the
popular culture so it wasn't that racism
became worse in the domain of real
interactions and then people noticed it
was that the journalists educated at
high-level institutions who were hired
by these uh hypothetical news sources
insisted that this was the case and
started to introduce that doctrine into
the entire culture and and well with
this bill for example being a late
consequence of that
well we can we can actually transpose
that we can transpose that onto
universities so um one of the
there was a guy uh paul calstad out of
um
texas a m and what he showed was that
the news media drive the perceptions in
the culture and then the culture kind of
becomes what the news media said it was
well that's going to happen with these
kind of bills as we pass them uh
provincially
you'll have students who never thought
about racial disharmony who suddenly
that becomes their their only thing on
their mind
and and it will just cascade the other
things we might want to point out is
that
this kind of propaganda is really easy
for incompetent people to teach
because you only have to master about
two principles so the first principle is
well let's say there's nothing that
motivates human beings and their
institutions accept the naked desire for
power
so okay and then the second thing is is
that
people should be categorized by group
and that doesn't require much
differentiated thinking because who
cares about all those pesky individuals
and then the third thing you have to
accept is that the world is best
construed as an eternal war between
oppressors and those who are victimized
and exploited by them by every
institution now master those three
things you can teach everything you need
to teach about diversity inclusivity
equity all of that
it's a substitute for actual knowledge
the fourth thing is you've got to keep
moving the goal close because for
revolutionaries the revolution can never
end i mean they're they're not in it for
it to end they're they're in it to keep
it going because that's what's exciting
for them so in other words what was
racist 50 years ago or 20 years ago uh
would be a racist action or or somebody
saying a terrible thing or the n word or
whatever it is now they since that's
diminished now they've moved the goal
post so that it's well it's unconscious
yeah you're not seeing oh it doesn't
matter if you don't see the racism then
there's these microaggressions and
there's there's what's in your mind it
used to be an action you used to have to
behave in a racist way now
they're telling you what's in your mind
and so you don't have to act at all you
can be what's even worse than that it's
worse than that barb as you pointed out
before because
you don't even have to to be prejudiced
you just have to be perceived as
prejudiced by someone that's it and that
actually because there's no you there's
no soul there there's no individual
there all you are
is the consequences of your actions and
you think could you come up with a
principle of justice more appalling than
that is that none of us are going to be
judged again on our intentions but only
by the worst consequences of our actions
unbelievable
barbara has has reminded me and she said
it really eloquently
uh of the idea of concept creep so
concept creep it was um
uh nick uh
haslam a guy at the university of
melbourne came out with this around 2016
and he was basically saying the
definition of negative
negative terms has expanded
so that's that's where you get uh
now racism
is equal to any kind of disparity
so if you see
unequal outcomes
that is de facto racism which is crazy
there are many reasons why there might
be uh different outcomes of which racism
is probably the least in our society but
now according to anti-racism and this is
really one of their key tenets of their
faith because it is like a religion they
say any disparity
is evidence of racism
and when you've got any suggestion to
the contrary is racism yes i agree
unless the disparity goes the wrong
direction
that's right right right right yeah
because yeah and that's the weird thing
that's the thing about this it's also so
peculiar because certainly the success
of asians in particular in let's say the
united states and canada
puts puts the
poses a significant challenge to the
domination theory it's like well so you
know asians are intrigued increasingly
treated like honorary whites in this
regard let's say well they're white
adjacent they're white adjacent right
exactly right right and and jews and
jews are considered hyper white hyper
white
because they used to be victims and now
they're victimizers there's a trap here
though there's a trap and the trapezius
it is a trap well the real trap is
to try and work this out
rationally in a way
that assumes it's rational and assumes
that it's consistent because those are
the two of the things that have been
rejected
if if things are not consistent if
they're not rational
they don't care about that that's not
the point
the point is to achieve what it is that
they have in mind all right so let's go
back to the the
so
let's go back to critical theory and
post-modernism just for a minute right
so there's there's post-modernism
suggests
that there is no such thing as objective
truth
right true truth truth is personal
and you know i could live with that
because the the logical extension of
that idea is well that everybody makes
up their own truth
so if you
think that you're a certain kind of
person and you want to believe that
that's fine and if somebody else
doesn't agree then that's fine too
because they have their truth
but the thing is that that idea that
truth is subjective
is not carried through
what they basically say is you know
there is no truth
except
our truth which you will comply with
under penalty and that's what this bill
is doing this bill says oh by the way
here's the truth you will do it or you
will be cast out
and not worse than that worse than that
you will do it
or you will be cast out
and we're going to insist that you
participate in the process by which your
children are led to think this way yes
right yes and that's a lot of that's
been rejected by parents in the us it
was that that just went too far they
would accept this to some degree for
themselves but parents wouldn't accept
it for their children
well they're accepting it here and there
something look i thought i thought the
rubber would hit the road with gender i
thought that parents would rise up uh
when their children were you know shown
the gingerbread
figure and unicorn
yeah the unicorn and and girls aren't
really well girls can be boys if they
want boys can be girls and i mean i i i
thought whoa whoa
parents will never accept this uh and a
few parents didn't but on the whole
um they as you say people don't want to
be shunned they don't want to be
isolated and they're afraid to
stick their heads over the parapet
especially canadians uh we don't have a
tradition of it um and i fear that this
this fascination with niceness uh will
be the death of us culturally because uh
you know at a certain point it is too
late
to turn back and i think once this bill
is passed that is a sign that um well
this is the permanent in in in ontario
the passing of this bill is
in some sense the permanent defeat of a
classically liberal or conservative
ethos
because it is it is capture of the
education system and so that isn't just
a battle that's won now that's a battle
that's won for the next 40 years and
it's a mandated victory
so it's a complete bloody catastrophe uh
no question it's it's it's
it's putting into formal legislative
terms what has really already happened i
mean
i'm not sure how much on the ground will
change it's just that now it is a
statutory mandate and and much more
easily enforced than it was before but
but the circumstances inside the schools
now and inside the universities
it is already traveled a a huge
distance to in in this direction
i think you're missing i think you're
missing one thing though bruce they'll
they'll be allowed to purge
oh yes they'll be able to be allowed to
purge the dissenters and and this is
what this is what will happen and you
know the dissenter is going to be the
person who puts forward empirical
evidence even though it's empirical but
it will somehow be deemed well that's
racist for example let's say that i i
bring out statistics canada data that
shows that right now um
asian canadians make more than uh
caucasian and black well if that offends
someone if that somehow
is deemed to be a racist because
remember racism is in the eye of the
beholder the person who's begrudged well
maybe now i can be purged for saying
something like that or what
maybe now you will be required to be
purged it's not even an allowance so you
understate the danger right
is that these boards are set up so that
the mandate is that anyone who expresses
opinions that can be uh mis interpreted
in any way as not anti-racist in this
strict sense so so divulging from the
equity doctrine in any way they have to
be
uh punished and and eliminated in some
in some true sense
so it's a complete route
it's a dystopia in statutory form
right
right well
well we probably
know
yeah well it's it is it is unbelievably
gloomy and to see the conservatives do
this to themselves is is
it's something
staggering to behold
i i every day something happens in
canada that i just can't believe would
happen and there it is it happens and
then the next day something that's even
more unbelievable happens
and now we have this bill and so
so as barbara pointed out
there there are some people who are
speaking out
there are people there's there's a new
group there's um
fair fair uh it's it's an organization i
think barbara has uh even written about
that
um i see that there's an ontario chapter
i think that slowly well i'm i'm hopeful
i i look at i look at groups like the
ontario party and i look at their policy
to try and reverse this i look at fair
and they're trying to organize parents
in a way that will
get rid of this critical race theory and
i think that these are green shoots
and
it's just getting momentum and then and
you know i'm going gonna make a
connection to current events i look at
what happened with the truckers the
freedom convoy
who would have thought that uh such
passive canadians would actually stick
it out and go and
uh peacefully protest as they did and if
you saw any of those uh overpass where
people were there cheering on the
truckers with their flags those are just
moms and dads everyday people maybe
they'll channel that same kind of energy
into the protection of their kids in the
school system
yeah and risk having their bank accounts
frozen
yeah and if only they had a political
party that they could invest all that
energy in the problem is they don't and
any that they do uh like the ontario
party is not going to grow though it's
going to stay fringe and it's going to
stay very tiny uh so
it's a serious problem
so let's say people should should go go
go ahead bruce i was just going to say i
do agree with dave that that that the
the
the trucker convoy and the phenomenon
that it that it launched is actually a
hopeful sign you've got you've got the
the shoots as you said of
of something coming together some kind
of political realignment or the coming
together of an actual opposition inside
the population
you know whether it will have
you know maybe able to be sustained and
grow remains to be seen but my goodness
that was that was the best
thing
that that i've seen happen in this
country for a long time
yeah well hopefully the conservatives at
least could be enticed to give voice to
some of that frustration in a manner
that was actually productive we could
hope that that would happen
i guess every we should ask people who
are listening
call your
mla
in ontario if you're in ontario call
your member of the provincial parliament
and let them know that you're not happy
about this right talk to people
write to the minister of education write
to doug ford
tell them
this has to stop and we should we should
underline the point that it's not
actually passed yet it's past second
reading it's going to committee it will
need to pass third reading so there's
time for the mpps to change their minds
on this so it's not actually done yet
if people are trying to
get an understanding of this um
john mcwhorter
who's at uh i think he's colombia he's
just written a book uh does anybody know
that is it woke racism is that what he
calls it
i think it is woke racism yeah
and uh really what he does is he says
why anti-racism exactly what's happening
with this bill why it is racist and he
takes a lot of time to explain it so
that's a read that some people might
want to
take a look at
yeah it's woke racism john mcwhorter
yeah so yes that would definitely be
worth taking a look at and so i want to
just close this
and sum up and you guys can make
whatever comments you want afterwards so
what we're seeing here to put it bluntly
just so everyone listening knows is that
a doctrine
of cultural criticism so radical
that moderate leftist democrats rejected
out of hand
is now going to be written into the law
governing all of our educational
institutions in a province in canada
governed by conservatives
right
yep now that's going to that propaganda
is going to become the mandated ethos of
the entire education system
and it's being done in such a
underhanded and
morally
manipulative manner that the very people
that it's being done to the most
intensely and that would be the
conservative types
are cowed into participating in the
process
yes yes absolutely
that's it
that's it
that's all folks
all right
thank you for
getting together so quickly everyone and
for being willing to share your
remarkably unpopular opinions
at some peril to yourselves
uh i was loving you didn't know what was
going on jordan but barb and i i i'm
hoping that the ontario party will make
some headway and barb is far more
realistic about this so i was i was
enjoying we were sparring a little bit
and you didn't even know
i was really i was really enjoying it
anyway it's it's it's good to be in such
uh
it's
although unpopular company uh
uh in our culture i consider it an honor
uh to be part of this small band of
brothers and sister
um and all the rest of us who are
uh
as i said to bruce before we started i
said it's it's kind of ironic that uh
everybody who agrees who's on our side
who's a dissenter uh on this we all know
each other and in a country of 38
million people that's that's kind of a
harsh uh reality uh sad that's a sad
reality but
say not the struggle not what's even
sadder i feel like cassandra you know
i look at these things i looked at them
10 years ago and i have this curse i can
see where things are going and
i think oh this is going in this
colossally stupid direction and it's it
can't be the case that it's really going
to get to that point is it and then it
just happens over and over and over and
over
and this bill is the most
this makes bill c-16 look like child's
play exactly this is exactly something
it's a hard it's a hard lesson to
swallow
they really mean it they really
mean it all of it
yep yep yeah
beware canadians you bloody well better
wake up
[Music]
you